we got this one from timcast.com quote
they will lose and they know it
Democrats will lose if election is a
referendum on Biden saki says follow the
money said the former press secretary
she says if it's a referendum on Biden
they're going to lose but if it's a
referendum on extremism they're going to
win all right here's the next story
Michael Moore predicts Democrat
Landslide against the traitors
Friday on HBO's real time liberal
documentary filmmaker Michael Moore
defied conventional wisdom and predicted
a landslide victory for Democrats in
November's midterm election
there are so many signs of this I think
honestly I think if we all do our work
and we all get people out to get out
there and we get ourselves I think we
can throw out a huge number of these
Republican traders in November he says I
think that there's going to be such a
landslide against the Traders especially
the 147 Republicans who just hours at
the Insurrection voted to not certify
the elected president of the United
States Joe Biden I think there's going
to be so many people coming out to vote
and then lastly with the hat trick from
the conservative brief pollster GOP
midterm turnout will exceed already high
expectations as parties fortunes grow so
what's it going to be saki says if it's
about extremism they win if it's about
Biden they lose Michael Moore says the
Democrats are going to win and then this
uh this pollster is saying that the
Republicans are going to win so uh what
what is it what do we got
yeah it's really hard to say I mean uh
it was uh Joe Rogan
um and another uh very popular
commentator I forgot his name right now
I'm blanking right now that that also
was from the left that came out and said
hey everyone should vote Republican for
this upcoming midterm it's going to be
was it that that was Rogan and somebody
else I forgot what's Kolinski
it was somebody it was somebody else
coming from a very surprising figure
that that you know shocked a lot of
people that that this person actually
said this I I have it somewhere here in
my notes uh but but it's going to be
interesting to see the turnout to see if
people actually do decide to vote or
whether they're just so disenfranchised
with this kind of emotional manipulation
that they're very much Aaron Rodgers
yeah yeah
commentator and I was like I thought it
was Aaron Rodgers it was yeah Aaron
Rodgers on Rogan but you know what was
interesting is that I think it does have
to do with if people are going to turn
out so many people are dissatisfied
nothing really seems to be going right
in the country you have Biden's really
horrible speech with his blood red
background you know speaking in front of
the Independence Hall I found it really
troubling that speech and I think a lot
of people did I talked to Democrats who
also found it troubling for different
reasons but
believed that it would be effective for
you know Democrats to be motivated to go
vote and I think it was to a certain
extent motivating for them the GOP I
think really should lean into the issues
that Americans care about McCarthy like
barely made any noise the other day even
though he gave that whole speech but you
did see him starting to unite a little
bit with the new right he had MTG
sitting right behind him in a pink
Blazer I was really glad to see her
there she's someone who initially I was
like I'm not so sure and I've really
come to have a lot of uh you know a lot
of respect for her I like her a lot so
um I liked to see that I like to see
that being a little more unified but I
think they have to lean more into the
new right stuff than the establishment
stuff well the the issue is that the
what people care about doesn't generate
clicks so if you're like let's talk
about economics the average the average
person is not going to share a story
that says like here's how we improve the
economy what's going to get shares is
like Trump supporters are fascists and
Democrats are giving children sex
changes right so those end up becoming
dominant issues and I'm not sure if
you've experienced this too but stories
about the border which people do say
they care about immigration border
stories like don't get a ton of shares
either why do you think that is I think
because it's super depressing to see
little kids abandoned at the border I
don't think we've had any reasonable
solutions that have been enacted other
than you know I mean during the Trump
years it slowed down substantially I
think
um but I just don't think it's an issue
that people want to deal with I think
people are primarily conflicted about it
and it's going to cognitive dissonance
yeah I think there's something like that
going on I think what I'm going to be
looking for in this upcoming midterm is
is one how many people come out two how
effective is social media going to be
and big and corporate media in in
swaying the emotions of people to vote a
particular way I think it's going to be
very interestingly because historically
uh the president's party loses the
midterms uh almost every time uh
throughout the the midterms that always
happened throughout uh you know the
latest uh the races that happened to
Obama right it happened to Obama that
happened I think to Bush as well uh it
happened 17 out of the 19 times uh since
the last last time so sorry the bazunkas
are I know I keep looking at a hard time
I'm actually wondering like is it is it
having an impact I think so I mean
there's Aaron Rodgers right behind me
and I was like who is that I don't know
I'm acting like a boob you're having
like baby brain over there I know I know
it happens it's it's you know the power
it gets to me here preparing to be a
parent
maybe uh I won't tell anyone my private
life but that's what yeah what we're
talking about here now the midterms here
as we're trying to focus here Ian before
the show when when Luke walks out with
the fake boobs skin goes he's looking
good
I should have wore a v-neck but uh
anyway uh it is going to be interesting
because it is going going to tell a lot
and it's going to foreshadow what's
going to be happening in 2024. so who's
going to have the power who's going to
have the influence who's going to have
you know the authority moving forward in
this country I think is going to dictate
a lot of uh you know a lot of the very
important like I just want to say you
know
in 2020 Texas filed a lawsuit against
Pennsylvania and you had about I think
46 states signed on to one side of the
lawsuit or the other questioning or
opposing the results of the election due
to uh procedural changes in certain
States so the Texas V Pennsylvania State
uh suit was specifically how
Pennsylvania handled the election
nothing to do with fraud it was about
like can you have Universal mail-in
voting and Texas was like
uh the Supreme Court said they wouldn't
hear it I think it was Thomas and Alito
said they would and I was kind of
shocked by this not really but they
should have heard the case Texas has a
right to make their argument as a state
in the Union I thought they should have
heard the case too yeah it's like
if there is a question about the
procedure by which a vote a procedure by
which which votes are cast and one of
the states says that what Texas
basically said is that Pennsylvania is
negating our votes by holding their
election in such a way that violates the
U.S Constitution right they also said
that the Pennsylvania was holding their
election in a way that I think violated
Pennsylvania law right and then which
was the violation yeah but then
ultimately I think the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court said no it's fine which is
just the whole thing's still contested
no one's satisfied with the results but
my point is not to say that anyone's
right or wrong in that whole argument we
can have an argument about that later my
point is when you have almost half the
country suing the other half like is
that not indicative of something really
crazy happening in this country then you
get January 6 then you get you know I
think uh Aaron Rodgers was killed before
January 6 right it was was it 2020 I
think Aaron Rodgers is the football
player yeah
I know there's a lot Daniel
was the Daniels versus Summer of 2020.
yeah wasn't he yeah Aaron Daniel said
right yeah yeah
um so you had you had that you have that
happen and then you get January 6th now
you you have a bunch of these stories in
Provo Utah they ramp to a BLM ran up to
a a random person and shot him in their
car that's a random person there was
something in Denver what was it what was
the thing in Denver the thing in Denver
there was a guy who had been sort of
hired as a security guard but had never
been vetted and shot a conservative
activist yeah and then after all of that
what I think happens is you're a frog in
a pot and the water's boiling and so
then you see people be like you know
what I went outside and nothing's
happening and it's like do you have
amnesia
did you forget everything that happened
in the past couple of years that's going
to be in the history books people do
forget everything right people forget
everything except what happens right
around when they're currently thinking
about everything you know they don't
think about what happened before
um everyone wants you to forget about
what happened in 2020 everyone wants you
to forget about covid they don't want
you to remember that your kids got sent
home from school that your kids are like
doing math at some grade level well
below their current age they don't want
you to think about any of that they're
just like that's over we're moving on
you know someone in the chat said crime
is not Civil War and I'm not saying it
is I'm saying that Bleeding Kansas also
wasn't Civil War but people were
fighting over the issue of slavery and
if we're now dealing with a story where
an old woman was shot in the back
because she was arguing about you know
being opposed to abortion many people
have argued that abortion could be the
moral Catalyst for us well you said that
yourself yeah yeah I've said it but but
many other smarter people than me have
made a similar point I think
um who was it was the guardian published
an article about it might have been
um I don't want I don't want to say the
wrong person so I'll avoid but it was
like a prominent leftist who said they
thought that abortion would be a would
be a candlest of Civil War not unlike
slavery yeah and so so now you have with
this is this is interesting with Lindsey
Graham pushing for a National 15-week
Abortion ban which only really helps the
Democrats but imagine if it has no
impact imagine if Republicans still win
and according to conservative brief win
better than anyone expected the left is
gonna be like okay now they're gonna
nationally ban abortion yo someone just
got shot for being pro-life what do you
think is going to happen if the
Republicans win in the midterms Joe
Biden will say I'll veto it Trump will
then say if you elect me in 2024 the
first thing I will sign is the 15-week
abortion ban right and then they're
going to be screaming and smashing
everything which will only make their
chances of winning worse I think it
should be a state's rights issue I think
yeah I agree I think it should stay
there it is a States right it is a
state's right to rights issue yeah
that's right and it's amazing and now
we're moving back into an era of
potential Civil War where there's a
states rights issue right around his
right to life always it's always a
state's rights issue yeah that's always
uh that's something that we come up
against Affairs everything should be a
state starts this year everything should
be busy with everything everything they
do have a constitution so a lot of stuff
isn't but for for uh someone like
Sheamus for instance he thinks it should
be banned federally because of murder
I'm sure most conservatives probably
think actually it's murder and it
shouldn't be allowed and then the more
like
governmentally conservative libertarian
types are like let the states decide but
on the moral question conservatives
outright are like no murder shouldn't be
allowed period so we're moving into this
similar territory to the first Civil War
I called the first Civil War 20. where
it's like the nation should ban the
murder of babies and unborn babies are
humans with unique DNA and and should
have a right should have protections
under the Constitution well that one
song was fascinating one side is saying
no to that
all right so so you saw you saw they
changed the definition of a heartbeat
they changed the definition of heartbeat
yeah and you know why they did they did
because of to back Stacey Abrams no they
changed it before she said that oh
really Planned Parenthood changed the
definition of of heartbeat uh they said
that it's not a heartbeat it's cardiac
activity at six oh well they were saying
that in 2017 as well
yeah yeah and the reason they did this
is because the heartbeat bills that are
being passed right so yeah they did that
in 2017 in the Atlantic and then in 2021
definition well they started talking
about what cardiac activity actually
means and then golden Parenthood did
blogs about it in 2021. they pass a law
that says once a heartbeat is detected
you can't get an abortion
says not heartbeat well that's you know
that's what it's been with so many
things you know I feel like we should
have a running glossary of words that
have been changed to suit the bite
Administration from heartbeat to
recession uh to vaccine efficacy you
know like all of these various things
um we used to know what the words mean
can just mean something different if
people in charge want it to well they
just change they get they get a bunch of
people to back it and then when you're
standing over here standing literally on
the word which reminds me of that old
gospel song from the 70s
um when you're over here standing on the
word and they're telling you the words
that you're standing on have now been
altered to suit their own political
machinations you know to suit their
their political needs it's a very
disconcerting to look at it and you know
and say like I thought this word mean X
and now it means something else to
everybody else thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there